DAVID KWONG: My name's
David Kwong.
I am both a magician and a "New
York Times" crossword
puzzle constructor.
That basically means I've taken
the world's two nerdiest
hobbies and put them right
into one career.
And it's a real honor for me
to share my art with all of
you, some of the most creative
and innovative
people on the planet.
What I'd like to speak to you
about today is the notion of
cross pollination.
Basically the idea of taking
different disciplines and
finding the common strains
within to synthesize something
new and creative.
And in my life, I've had three
very different passions,
magic, puzzles, and movies.
And somehow, surprisingly,
they've all
come together recently.
So I'm excited to share
those with you today.
So do we have any "Scrabble"
players in the house?
"Scrabble" players?
"Words with Friends" players?
Yes?
"Bananagrams?" "Scramble?" I
love "Scramble." I play it
like half an hour a day.
I'd like to teach you a little
bit about "Scrabble." And it
involves bingoing.
I'm going to try something
with the
"Scrabble" tiles here.
And I would like this young
man here to please grab a
handful of tiles
out of the bag.
Yes.
Very good.
And would you grab a handful
of tiles out of the bag?
AUDIENCE: Can he do it?
DAVID KWONG: Yes.
You may do it.
Your name is Ethan.
No, you have a name tag on.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KWONG: Ethan, Ethan, drop
them in the cup for me.
Ethan, drop those tiles
in the cup.
Very good.
Have you drop your tiles
in the cup, sir.
Very good.
And would you grab some tiles?
Now, I'm taking a selection
from you.
There are 100 tiles
in the bag.
There are nine A's and one
Z. And would you grab--
Oh, thank you so much.
That was an O. OK.
Now, you'll notice I'm not
using the whole bag.
Let's turn the projector
on, if you don't mind.
Because if I were to use the
whole bag, then I would able
to memorize exactly
what to do here.
But I'm using a selection of
tiles from all of you.
And I will bring this around
so you can actually
read what I'm doing.
Turn this on.
And my goal here is to
bingo using the tiles
you've given me.
And I will make it a little
more difficult.
Actually, let me first tell
you about bingoing.
Here's how we bingo at a
competitive level in
"Scrabble."
You take something like the
tisane list, that's
T-I-S-A-N-E, tisane.
It's a type of herbal tea.
That's a six letter strain, and
it consists of very easy
letters to anagram.
So if you were to get the Z, or
the Q, or the X, you don't
want to hold onto them.
You want to get rid of them
right away and end up with
S's, and T's, and R's, and A's,
and very easy letters
with which to anagram.
This six letter strain you can
add a seventh letter to, and
you can bingo for
the tisane list.
Now, it works for every letter
except Q, Y, or J. It doesn't
work for those.
But it works for the other 23.
So, sir, would you
give me a letter?
I'll demonstrate the
tisane list.
AUDIENCE: H.
DAVID KWONG: So H plus
T-I-S-A-N-E, you can spell
"shitane." Shitane,
which is a bingo.
And would you give
me a letter?
AUDIENCE: R.
DAVID KWONG: R plus T-I-S-A-N-E.
You actually also
create the satire list.
So there are a plethora of
bingos like retains and
retinas, stainer and restain.
And last, one final letter.
AUDIENCE: L.
DAVID KWONG: L. You can spell
"elastin," which I think is a
type of protein.
You actually don't have to
know what they mean in
"Scrabble." You just have
to know they're words.
And you can keep me honest
with this dictionary from
1996, which was my best
friend in high school.
Maybe my only friend
in high school.
So my goal here is to bingo
using these tiles.
And to make it a little more
difficult, I will go for
eight-letter bingos.
And I will try to interlock
the rest of the
tiles at the same time.
And to add a ticking clock, I
will try to do this in under
three minutes.
Here we go.
Now, can we see the timer?
Three minutes to make three--
that's a blank--
eight-letter bingos and
rearrange the rest of the
tiles at the same time.
Here we go.
OK, so you have given me
C-W-M, which is a great
vowel-less word, "cwm,"
which is a cirque.
It's a lake.
It's a Celtic word, I believe.
Let's do--
well, you gave me the
K, which is good.
So let's do walk.
And sidewalk is my first
eight-letter bingo, sidewalk.
If you get lots of vowels,
you have to dump them.
This is an anoa.
The anoa is a Southeast
Asian water buffalo.
I'll place that there.
Ka is the Egyptian soul.
But I need to use that K again,
so we'll stick that
there and do via.
And let's--
Do I have another S?
Good.
This will turn into--
if I have the letters--
skydive.
Take this V back.
We lost the timer.
Skydived.
OK.
And last but not--
I need another eight-letter
bingo.
Ae is an old way of saying
the number one.
We have bed.
If you have two U's, you might
want to dump them with the
ulu, which is an Eskimo knife.
The ulu.
Those are legit too.
You have to know your
two-letter words.
There are 100 of them.
OK, row.
And I need one more, so let's
take this B and do-- and this
L-- and do bull here.
With this W, we can spell
"bullwhip." A bullwhip is an
eight-letter bingo.
So let's see if I can get
through the rest of these in
under the time.
We have nay, up.
OK, 50 seconds to get
through these.
Ram, let's do row again.
How am I doing on time?
AUDIENCE: 45.
DAVID KWONG: OK.
Fa.
OK.
[SIGH].
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KWONG: You gave me a
lot of vowels, people.
OK, we'll do it.
The two letter words, you can
see, are essential to getting
through this.
20 seconds.
OK.
This is killing me.
Deer.
Ire works here.
AUDIENCE: Three, two, one.
DAVID KWONG: There we go.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID KWONG: I really just
didn't use a couple of
letters, a C and an E. But
I did accomplish what
I set out to do.
Bullwhip, sidewalk
and skydived.
And it's good that I didn't use
a couple of letters, a C
and an E, because I'm going to
tell you a little bit about
"Scrabble" scoring.
Who can tell me what happens
when you don't use a couple of
letters in Scrabble?
AUDIENCE: You lose the points.
DAVID KWONG: You lose
the points, and your
opponent gets them.
But actually now with inflation
in the scoring
system, you actually just get
double what your opponent was
left over with.
And I'm going to draw
your attention over
here to this board.
So it was, what was it?
A C and an E, right?
A C and an E, which is a
net of eight points.
But I did make three
eight-letter bingos, skydived,
bullwhip, sidewalk.
Now, I'll put in the unique
values for the letters.
And these never change.
For those of you unfamiliar
with "Scrabble," the S is
always one, the K
is always five.
There's only one K in the bag.
But I managed to make
it intersect, so I
have it twice on here.
And I'll put the rest in.
The Y is four, two, one,
four, one, and two.
And three, one, one, one, four,
four, one and three.
And one, one, two, one, four,
one, one, and five.
I play a lot of "Scrabble."
Now, with these three
eight-letter bingos, if you
add them vertically, you
actually get a new eight-digit
number, right?
So let me show you
what I mean.
If we were to take the S, plus
the B, plus the S, that's like
a one plus a three plus a one.
That's a five.
Now, I just want to review that
there were some puzzle
pieces in play before.
And one of them was
a piece of fruit.
You cut open the fruit, you
pulled out from within it a
dollar bill.
And that was your dollar
bill, sir.
Yes?
And you still have your
dollar on it.
You signed it.
You have it.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID KWONG: You'll notice on
your dollar that there's an
eight-digit serial number
on that dollar bill.
AUDIENCE: Ohhh!
DAVID KWONG: Would
you take a look?
Does the first number to the
far left-- is it a five?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DAVID KWONG: It is.
What's just to the
right of that?
AUDIENCE: Holy cow.
DAVID KWONG: Holy--
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID KWONG: What's just
to the right of that?
Is it a seven?
Five plus one plus
one is seven.
AUDIENCE: Seven.
DAVID KWONG: What's just
to the right of that?
AUDIENCE: Seven.
DAVID KWONG: Because four plus
one plus two is seven.
Just to the right of that?
AUDIENCE: Four.
DAVID KWONG: Two plus one
plus one is four.
Just to the right of that?
AUDIENCE: Nine.
DAVID KWONG: One plus four
plus four is nine.
Just to the right of that?
AUDIENCE: Nine.
DAVID KWONG: We should
have another nine.
Four plus four plus
one is nine.
And what do we have just
to the right of that?
AUDIENCE: Four.
DAVID KWONG: Here's what's
interesting.
We have D plus P plus
K. That is a zero.
Carry the one, mind you, carry
the one to get a four.
And that should match
your dollar bill.
I think it does.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID KWONG: Thank you.
Jonathan, you'll notice also
that there are two letters
that surround that
serial number.
AUDIENCE: Oh my.
DAVID KWONG: What are they?
AUDIENCE: C--
DAVID KWONG: They're a C and an
E. So thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE]